hey Neil Homer with a thousand bits is
that a question if people cheer and ask
questions this might be might be more
incentivizing you see if I can get that
or wait no it's it's Niall Homer Niall
as in file okay you can't stay long okay
how would you go about learning a
repertoire from a particular opening
book I find the multiple sidelines and
the example games confusing yeah all
opening books are different some books
are better organized and others I guess
what I can do is paste in the question
as a new chapter add new chapter
creating a repertory from an opening
book pace a comment this will be hard to
answer without actually like going
through the process but I can give you
some tips the first and I think most
important piece of advice I would give
is save everything even if you're
playing playing stuff out using like a
physical board if you're creating a
repertory you should save your analysis
in a digital format Lee chess is great
for that most people I recommend using
me chess because it auto saves and you
can organize things what I can do is
just show you kind of the starting
points and then if you have follow-up
questions you can you can feel B field B
be free to ask in a later point and the
mofei this will help anyone who maybe
wants to learn from a book but wants to
save everything they learn and be able
to review it on their computer or tablet
or phone so the
step in the process create a new study
if it's a rapper tour then I recommend
having one study for your white openings
and one study for your black openings so
to make a study you just go to a beach
house start work study new study I
actually have many different repertories
saved for myself and for students and
sometimes you'll get to that points if
you're playing different things or
you're teaching but for most people just
create something that sets black
openings and then every chapter should
be a different variation so I don't know
if you're still in the chat or if you
already left but if there is a specific
variation that you're studying then all
right let's say a specific opening that
you're studying trying to think of an
example let's say a variation against
the French one that I played before like
two nights attack what I would do is
create different chapters based on
different different sequences so let's
say I'm learning the two nights attack
just create a chapter two nights attack
and then what I would do is when I'm
first starting I just keep everything in
one chapter but then over time I'll
split it up so two nights attack for
those who don't know at least against
the French is when you develop two
nights as early as possible
and within this opening there are three
main moves in this position for black
there is d4 there's D takes e4 and
there's -6 there's also some lesser
common moves like this ship before and
night night c6 which if you wanted to
you could maybe eventually study in your
repertory but if you wanted to maybe
prioritize learning the first first main
lines what I would do is create separate
chapters for each each deviation a black
and choose from so well I'll go ahead
and do is label this actually change the
name and just call this overview and
then I'll make another chapter two
nights attack what was the move number
remove three three nine f6 is a mainline
and then this chapter will be devoted to
the main line resulting after Knight f6
and then I would save the variations and
an analysis which can stem from this
position so just to show maybe to
provide some value I know there was some
comments recently people were asking for
like a video series on the two nights
attack which I'm still working on I'm
actually thinking about creating a
course on like a whole repertoire for
whites but just to show like some fun
analysis this is one of the main lines
where light controls the center with the
pawns at first but then very soon white
is okay trading off the pawns like after
a c5 light can take on c5 the main
difference between this variation and
like typical advanced variation of the
French as that white doesn't have c3 in
this position because the Knights on c3
so White's prioritizing development of
the minor pieces usually black plays
Knight c6 attacking and five white can
defend with Bishop to f4 if I wanted to
I should point out that if you draw
arrows or highlights in a study
everything saves so if I were to review
this later and I'm playing through the
line like the arrow is just safe so
sometimes that can be useful so Bishop
f4 defending the pawn and now a very
common trap players will fall into is
from this position black will castle and
anyone who watches my stream religiously
will have at least seen a few games I've
played in this line where
is just crushing after Bishop takes h7 a
very nice example of the Greek gifts
where after Kim takes h7 Knight g5 black
is pretty much defenseless most players
will play King g8 and then queen h5 if
Locke wants to delay getting Maeda you
can play rookie Yates but then white is
meeting and five I think one two three
so this probably applies more to higher
level players where you're actually
taking a much deeper approach and
learning just beyond the first few moves
of it and opening but this is really the
first step in kind of building a
repertory is saving kind of the skeleton
variations and then seeing where things
can deviate other great thing about me
chess is that we can we can save all the
different sub lines to like I'll
actually say that okay castling is of
course a blunder so we can highlight
that just mistake it's not Bishop d3 g3
is very normal
casting it's a blunder the main line
here is pawn at six and whatever you're
building a repertoire it's really
important to stay organized because you
can very easily get carried away and
have like a bunch of different sub lines
and the notation and just be overwhelmed
so usually the most popular or the best
variation should be promoted to the main
line in this case we can click make main
line and then in this specific position
white has to take white actually gives
away both Center pawns but keeps a
pretty good grip on the center black
usually takes back and then if I'm
teaching this to someone for the first
time usually I'll say play Queen e2 and
then I'll stop in this position but then
draw a bunch of arrows just to show the
middle
ideas from this position like wants to
Castle queenside
usually go for a 95 and then go for some
King side attack with g4 g5 and there
are some nice games which can
demonstrate this but sometimes when
you're reading from an opening book you
want to decide what to save and what not
to save so sometimes you don't need to
save a whole game you just want to save
kind of a skeleton variation and save
the relevant sub variations and then
over time you can continue to add to to
your analysis another nice line I'll go
ahead and show so I feel like anyone who
wants to learn how to play against a
French this is a great option and
there's a sneakier trap for whites
starting with Queen b6 after Queen b6 it
looks like black is winning upon
attacking b2 and f2
usually if Queen b6 is play that's a
good sign black is about to fall into
the trap white can castle here like will
usually take on me to thinking that
white blundered but now there's a very
strong move for white like B 595 not
only attempts to trap the Queen in many
cases but it's threatening Knight c7 if
Bishop DC or Bishop to b6 and there's 96
check which is pretty devastating so
I've had this position as well a few
times on stream and a lot of players
will Castle and then white can still go
for the great gift with Bishop takes h7
exclam after King takes h7 Knight g5
King G eights I like teaching this to
students because the the next move is
really important and most people who I
show this to won't play the right move
as white salt poses as a question to the
chat's white to move what's the best
continuation and let me
whether it's yeah okay whites in
I see a couple wrong moves almost
everyone is saying the wrong move I
think only one person has said the right
move now a couple people saying the
right move
97 doesn't hurt says biscuit fiend yeah
- everyone's saying Queen h5 you're
wrong let's start with Queen h5 and then
we'll get to the right move Queen h5 is
a blunder even though it looks similar
to the previous line White's fretting me
to the rook moves f7 Falls now black has
a very nice and simple defense Locke can
just take on c2 defending from a
distance and white sacrifice to Bishop
and just doesn't have a great follow up
to the attack so it's a clever response
from black I'm pretty sure there's been
a handful of games played on me chess in
this position switch databases you had
21 games black found Queen Dixie - and
blacks just much better here so the best
move which a few people found is Queen
d3 very similar idea threatening mate
not too many options for black to defend
if black plays g6
which looks most natural then white has
Queen h3 and now okay same idea White's
running mates but in this case because
black played g6 it lets trucks dead
diagonal for defense of the Queen and
whites just made in here I don't think
there's any way to actually stop me
maybe there's one way to delay mate with
Bishop takes f2 but then there's King h1
so okay I think this was all based off
of Nile homers question which when he
asked it it was like ten minutes ago and
then he said he had to go
well hopefully that's a thorough answer
and hopefully people can gain some value
from at least using a leech a study to
create a repertory this very powerful
tool if you're reading from a book and
you're using the book is kind of your
main your main sort of knowledge base
then you can also add some comments and
annotations which I encourage people to
do sometimes I'm lazy to do it but Queen
g3 we can say brilliant provoking black
play g6 and instructing the e1 to h7
diagonal so lacks queen can't defend
okay I recommend especially for the
players who want to try and like
remember their their openings I
recommend having maybe some small
comment with each move just like saying
the purpose because if you know the
purpose behind each move even if you
forget it
hopefully you understand what's going on
and you can figure it out
okay now I'll homer is still here okay
that's good to see someone asking about
f5 and oh I five after Queen d3 another
variation think after f5 if we take on
passant there is Knight takes and I the
knight would defend each seven so I'm
thinking either Knight takes c6 or Queen
h3 when I saw the openings I usually try
and use a bunch of different things
between the database if I'm looking at a
book I'll use the book analysis and then
also stockfish and then also in my own
brain so sometimes what I would do here
is I'd probably predict Queen h3 is the
best move
but then I would just verify with stock
fish stock fish is really good in these
types of positions yeah queen h3 and we
can press spacebar for lazy I just spits
out the stock fish line queen age seven
I'll cook me one first
I don't like rookie one let's go for the
kill here here Queen a chance ah now
Knight takes c6 yeah this is just so
much fun for white and we can safely say
that white is winning